welterweight champion camaro usman  shared what he believes to be some harsh  truths about conor mcgregor during his  appearance on the im athlete podcast  he's not necessarily done but he's done  as a champion this is my perspective  because when i fight guys i study their  hearts when i watch fights i watch their  heart and for me he's done he's done  because i don't know whether the goal  was to get the money when asked whether  he would fight mcgregor kamaru expressed  it as an opportunity he couldn't pass up  he could call me out but that don't mean  he's going to fight me it's not  necessarily that they protect him  because he's bigger to where he can pick  where he can call his shots he's that  big conor can say i'm going to fight you  tomorrow and he's still gonna sell 1  million buys absolutely i'd grab that  check